you wore bra less and crazy cousin hot
ain't nobody going to Korea in the
summer he's gonna die out there you
kidding me Hyuna bro unless I'm not
gonna walk out there with no t-shirt on
in the summertime in Korea are you crazy
your ass is coming I'm here with my
Korean American friends to talk about
growing up in America I was born in
Louisiana grew up in Georgia I came here
when I was 16 so I came to America 2010
after I graduated high school from Korea
I used to live in Orange County area and
moved to Fullerton and moved to LA about
three years ago I was born in San
Francisco and I lived out in Korea since
I was 1 and then I moved back here in
2nd grade I was born in Korea but I
moved to America when I was 12
since then I haven't been back yet I
[Music]
went to the dentist I I guess they can't
remember my name
and then they wrote on there you cut off
really yeah it just really looks I don't
cuz they knew I was speaking English and
I wasn't like yo I'm Korean like you
know I mean this that's gonna happen but
these days there's a lot of people who
go out to Korea to teach English and
stuff so you'll meet a lot of people who
speak English just as much as you do
there are a lot of foreigners living in
Korea so I thik hurryin with my parents
fully but like because I did their
growing up like here I feel weird
speaking Korean to people like my age
you haven't heard of it no I talked to
my Korean language it's like elementary
school level so I wouldn't know any of
the new slang I would have know what to
say
I think when you go to Korea the wait
everyone grows up it's different so even
though I was raised in Korea like when I
was young and then I went back when I
got older I still had a depression
because it was so different
[Music]
I go both ways I spoil them I still kind
of root for Korea I think I look root
for Korea more Korea versus America then
I will for sure
root for Korea but like America versus
other country it's done yeah I think
yeah well sad I think that's what I wish
so I watch more American TV shows but I
laugh more at Korean shows it's just not
really it's funnier the way they react
with each other on TV I feel like Korea
has a really good reality program it's
like so funny I love to wear don't wanna
share a body bar there's an Ellen Show
okay then Ellen Show sometimes when I
watch American shows I don't understand
anything
I don't get their humor like the dry
humor is not funny to me
I don't get the Korean yeah I have to
look at the subtitles you know the
captions when I come out like oh that's
a Korean reality shows are more like
people suffering like in a funny way you
know like baby
yeah games and like they've living in
like small houses and like doing things
challenges together and I think it's
funny or to see people like going
through hard things but like laughing
through it I find that like Korean
variety shows it's more involved only
celebraties but in America
there are some like just regular people
involved in the lot of variety shows so
I think that's I gotta yeah yeah I grew
up in Diamond Bar and they have a bunch
of like Korean people
I definitely hung out with mostly all
Korean yes so when I came here I didn't
know who to hang out with because Harris
County just it's black and white and
then me you know in my aunt you know but
she don't go to school with me it was
just like whoa so overwhelming for me so
I had a really thick accent when I first
came here and they're like you have an
accent
no you have an accident you know and
then I just felt kind of like kind of
like stuck one thing that really
bothered me if you act like to Asia and
if you have Asian friends if you look
age and if you dress the Asian you're
called fob right and people look down on
you people are like why are you even in
America if you act American or if you
have more white friends or if you dress
Lesley not that Asia you're called a
whitewash like yeah ever since I dyed my
hair blonde I've seen comment saying
like oh she's white watch she's trying
to be white and maybe I dye my hair
because I like the color maybe I want to
have a change just like how everyone
does their hair color growing up and
especially in middle school because of
that flop stereotype I think that's why
I tried so hard to hang out with
American people and I wish I made more
Korean friends there but I was so
worried that we called it Bob
and then now like people calling you
white was just because you're acting
that asian it's like so not fair to be
on each side I think we need to stop
thinking we have to be one getting
better than before yeah like these days
I kind of feel that way yeah I wish I
came to America earlier because I came
to America when I was getting into
college so I didn't really get to hang
out with white or black or like there's
been a gathering races I hung out with
mostly Korean and other Asians like
Taiwanese Chinese whenever I meet other
race friends in class they would bind
Korean related thing and they would only
talk about like that like kpop yeah kpop
or like I've been to Korea
like considering you came that you came
in high school yeah you're really really
good when I first met her that's like
one of the first things I said I had no
idea you came when you were 19 like
that's crazy
you're lying
English English oh when I get really mad
just English I don't cause in Korea at
all when I cussing in English it doesn't
sound bad you know everybody says like
in Korean if you're like being Oh cuz
you don't tip in Korea at all now that I
think about it cuz in Korea you don't
tip and that sounds so nice but now I
think in Korea they don't get tips so I
feel bad for them
I literally taught my friend that's just
that's visiting from Korea how do tip I
was like you just times this by you know
15% or 20% another culture shock this is
a good thing but whenever like strangers
they smile yeah
there you won't they don't like to talk
to strangers in Korea but here they're
like hi it's a stranger and career
they're like we're gonna be like ah you
know your age you're one year younger
here right and it just sucks cuz
sometimes I very clear that I hold are
you I'm like oh um example 24 and then
like I come here and I'm like oh I'm 24
oh just kidding I'm 22 or 23
all of a sudden we're cool but we were
always cool yeah
without the kpop but we're still us you
know cool we can still dance we can
still thing like but then again that's
what's making us more noticeable kpop
kdramas definitely put like a big big it
doesn't stop but we were always cool
yeah yeah every little bit more aware
that it's getting known time and
Pavlovian on culture to them with how to
eat them and they're like you have to be
brave and be ready to embrace I think
like when you first come you need to
kind of feel out of your circle even if
you're uncomfortable try your best to
learn English so adapt to dis culture
and then you can still keep your culture
where you came from which is Korea that
way you can really become like a Korean
American try to keep both culture if you
don't want to grow up only being English
and forgetting the Korean but you want
to keep the both that I think both
cultures have amazing things and I was a
super shy kid when I was little I know
it's really hard to tell now there's a
lot of mean kids out there and when
those kids would pick on me I I would go
home crying like am i ugly like what's
wrong with me like is there something
wrong with me I didn't understand what
was going on but you know that's just
ignorance be fearless no beer whatever
you want do you yeah yeah
[Music]